all right let's try efore best my test
Fisher okay alpen now what d 5 I have a
lot more learning to do with this open d
6 that's I'm sure about d6 college black
going to respond to d for capturing
white is doing really well if there's a
capture nice enter the C 3 square would
be vacated and well that's it's about it
I'd have three f4 Knight f3 now let's
speed things up here I'd f3 no need to
throw the f pun this is a good enough
center if my e4 pawn comes under fire I
can follow up with Bishop d3 take care
of Sean CC
hmm
well there is the possibility for takes
like if I play Bishop d3 here takes
takes night b4 actually that's not
working now that'll just backfire on
black if they run for it because I have
Queen a four I'm not winning a piece but
I'm just forcing the night to go back
actually no I would be winning a piece
because i have an ensuing d5 available
okay well now what I'm just going to
Castle so is this really going to happen
the capture you'll notice I'm delaying
this Knights move because maybe black
will be capturing on d4 and I could just
recapture and make use of the classic
square C 3
alright
oh man where we got me five chase this
night away or rip to e1 pont push take
take and then the night has to go
somewhere else try it v5 takes takes
this night has to find a new home
I don't know what the ok so now okay
clearly my night will not be making use
of this square and I don't want to take
the time out to play see 493 now that
the position has opened up time is a
much bigger factor and wasting it with
c4 night here don't know what the if
that would be any good at all so queen e
to rookie one I like queen e to this is
coming under fire so let's get clean e2
and if more pressure is placed against
this part I'll be kind of torn between
either rook to e1 or Bishop to f4 keep
in mind the following there is a
significant difference between Bishop f4
and rookie one in the sense that if you
play Bishop f4 let's say a response to
Queen c7 then there is maybe the
possibility for a change in the
structure with f5 knowing that I don't
have this capture because of Queen takes
bishop if all that if Queen c7 Bishop f4
I don't know if it's the greatest thing
in the world are on with but it's at
least available at five and then my
bishop is shut down on this diagonal
rook to this square Bishop here if I
play Bishop f4 is g5g for stuff going to
happen could very easily could very
easily happen I think a for just to stop
this move a4 with night a three to see
for i think is a an idea again I'm going
to be extra cautious about throwing my
bishop here because of this expansion I
don't know if I really want to get a
kicked around here
now I
let's see
Bishop f4 rook d1a 4983 I don't I'm
really fearful this g5 move so Bishop f4
mmm
oh man if I play night to d2 and b5 is
played I can't go to c4 and if I play to
e4 this pond falls mmm i'm going to try
a 4 let's see if they Castle kingside I
have this move available of course there
is f5 to shut down the diagonal and if I
capture the night can recapture and
defend h7 so we'll see about that black
is already under a minute or 10 minutes
oh yeah 10 minutes where we're 10 moves
into the game I've spent quite a bit of
time as well so this is my first thought
just going right for the jugular here
making one threat mmm Queen here f5
takes takes the knight hits my queen I
think I could use some more development
I'm going to play Bishop here now and
I'm definitely not as afraid of g5 in
this instance because the King has
declared his intentions already he is
now on the Kings side so just looking to
finish my development this night
eventually getting to maybe d 6 or maybe
even f6 with some tactics and hmm
I play here f5 I think I should just
take let's take and then back my bishop
up I'm assuming it's going to get hit
real soon right now I ok if the night
takes I don't have ok the rook is taking
so if I play here I'm winning this pawn
pretty sure of that mmm Bishop g5 rook
takes Knight Bishop takes bishop I'm a
queen ok that's not working so it's not
what would be working for black so this
is a classic deflection the rook for
this one moment is constrained to the
defense of this pond and now I could
take it but not with check and I might
actually lose my bishop if I did that so
I have to do something there my plan
here is to get developed still I'm fully
developed at this point and there's just
no time for black let's go back a good
game hitting back and flipping the
screen here from your perspective right
here I've said it before I've for the
handful of times that I have played this
as white I recommend he trying for that
d 5 move instead of d 6 i've seen d6
played quite a bit but i think this is
the way to go knowing that after you
recapture with your queen in the Senate
I don't have c3 available for my night
to be then gaining a tempo on your queen
so look into d5 and because now it's
tough how you eventually have to
challenge these pawns in some way and
they weren't really challenged and
because of it I'm able to cement upon on
e5 and it becomes very awkward for you
to complete your development United's
getting kicked away to a squared like
well where did you go he went to d7 so
it's just very uncomfortable this is a
really good square for your night so
take that into a
out and how you can be taken that into
account is to maybe run with d5 right
now if we have the exchange of my epon
in your deep on then that means your
night going to be a bit more comfortable
once he's played to f6 so just just a
quick pointer right there not to get
super elaborate or anything but